This is an HTML Crash Course. I'm Beau Carnes
and I'm going to teach you the basics of HTML.
Let's jump right into it. You probably already
know that HTML is used to create web pages.
It stands for Hypertext Markup Language. Every
website on the internet uses HTML and CSS. Most
also use JavaScript. In a website, HTML is the
structure. CSS is the style, and JavaScript is
the functionality. Here's a great interactive
diagram from code analogies calm, you can see
we have the page, the structure, styling
and functionality, and we move this slider.
So it's like the house. So pages like the house.
So the structure or the HTML is like how many
bedrooms or how many rooms, the CSS, the styling
is like the color, the color of the brick here.
And then the functionality of what you're doing
like eating is the JavaScript, you can actually
see the HTML that makes up any element on a web
page by right clicking an element, and then going
to inspect. And this, all this right here is the
HTML. In this crash course will mainly discuss
HTML. Afterwards, you'll probably want to learn
CSS and JavaScript. At the end of this course.
I'll also show you how to get your HTML page
online using hosting or.com. to host the website
hosting are provided a grant that made this
course possible. Hosting her provides web hosting
databases, domains and other services. Before you
learn how to write HTML, you have to make sure you
have a place to write the HTML, a program used
to write code or HTML is called a code editor.
There are a few places you can write HTML online
without installing anything, such as code pin.io,
or replique Comm. I'll quickly show you how
to use code pin to write HTML, then I will
show you how to install and use a program
on your computer called Visual Studio code.
I'm going to be using Visual Studio code for this
course. But you can use any code editor you like.
If you already know where you're going to write
your HTML, you can jump right to the part of the
course where I start teaching HTML. So if you
want to use code pen, which is the easiest way
to get started, we can just go to code pen.io,
and then click start coding. So you can see
there's a place for HTML, CSS, and JavaScript. But
we're just going to be doing HTML in this course.
So let me show you an example. If I make
a paragraph, and type in hello world,
you can see that it appears right down here.
And then it keeps updating automatically,
you can see it updated with my mistake, and then I
corrected it and then it went back to the correct
way hello world. So you can also just change
move these stuff around, change the view. And
this can make it a little easier to write the
HTML on this side and then see the result on
this side. Now I'll show you Visual Studio code.
If you just do a search for Visual Studio code,
you can go right in here. And then I
will click download, and the button
will automatically download Visual Studio code
for whatever operating system you're using. I'm
not going to show the full download and install
process that should be pretty self explanatory.
Once you get Visual Studio Code opened, it should
look something like this, you won't have these
recent files here. And also I zoomed in a little
bit so everything's a little bigger on the screen.
But you're going to want to click new file.
And now I'm just going to go to File, Save.
And for the title, I'm going to type in index
dot HTML and make sure you are in the directory
you want. I already created a directory called
HTML course. So it's pretty standard to name your
main file index dot HTML. In fact, web browsers
will often look for a file with that exact name.
When your website is loading up. You can actually
call your HTML file anything it could be called
cats, dot HTML or new dot html.
But it's generally good to stick
with index dot HTML for your first file.
Okay, you got a place to write the HTML.
Let's start writing HTML. In this course, you will
learn HTML by creating a simple page. I recommend
that you type along with me will create a web page
line by line and I'll explain the key concepts
as I go. I'm going to first create an extremely
basic HTML page and then I'll explain it
okay HTML is made up of elements in element is
an individual component of HTML. So this right
here is an H one element, an element will often
have an opening tag like this, and a closing tag,
and it will contain everything within the opening
and closing tags, you can see a closing tag often
has a slash right in these angle brackets right
before the name of the tag. So this is an h1 tag
that's opening and closing h1 tag. Most elements
are container elements. That means they hold
content between the opening and closing tags.
For instance, it's this h1 element is holding
the content, hello world. But some elements are
stand alone, like this one right here. And we'll
talk about a few more later. This one right here
doctype doctype. html. This is what all HTML files
are going to start with. This is the first element
on every HTML page, it tells the browser to expect
HTML and what version to use. And this just
means to use the newest version of HTML.
And then we have this HTML element. So this is the
opening tag. And this is the closing tag. And all
of this are the contents of the HTML element. All
page content must be contained in these HTML tags.
And then we have this body tag here. So here's
the opening body tag and the closing body tag.
And here is the contents of the body, the body
is going to contain all the visible content in
a page, often above this body element within the
HTML element, you're going to have a head element
that is going to contain the page title and
metadata. We'll talk about that much later. So
for now, let's focus on this the h1 hello
world, the H in h1 stands for headings.
So h1 is is an h1 element is used to define
headings, and there's h1, h2, h3, h4 h5, h6,
and the one is going to be the biggest Heading
Two is going to be slightly smaller, three is
gonna be smaller still, and so on. So let's see
what this looks like in an actual web browser.
So I'm going to save this Command S or Ctrl S,
or you can go to File, Save. And now I'm going to
open this in a web browser. To do this. To open
it, I'll just find the file in my file browser.
So here's my folder. Here's the file, I just
created index dot HTML, I'll just double
click that file. And you can see it says hello
world. That's the h1 element I just created.
Let me reposition these windows. That's better.
Now I can see the HTML code on this side.
And I can see the web browser what the HTML
is creating over on the right side. So I told
you there are different types of headings like
h1, h2, h3, I'm gonna create another heading.
So h two, and I'm gonna call this
cat photo app. And if I save this,
and then I refresh, you can see hello world is
really big. And then cat photo app is a little
smaller because it's an h2 element. Another
common type of element is a p element. A p
element is used to create paragraph text on
websites. So I'm going to create a p element,
you may have noticed that the code editor
automatically puts the ending tag, when I put the
beginning tag, the code editor is automatically
going to put the ending tag right in here for us.
So that's pretty nice. And you may have also
noticed that the beginning and ending tag can
be on the same line like the h1 element, or they
can be on different lines like this body element.
Okay, so right within this paragraph tag, I'm
going to put Click here to view more cat photos.
And if I save this and refresh, we can see the
paragraph. paragraph text is the main text on a
web page that people read. Okay, now I'll talk to
you about commenting. Comments allow you to leave
messages without affecting the output displayed
to the end user. It's common in pretty much all
programming languages to have comments. It also
allows you to make code inactive. For instance, if
we put this h2 element within the inside a comment
then it wouldn't appear on the page anymore.
So let me show you how to add a comment. I'm gonna
put less than sign exclamation point dash dash.
And then the code editor automatically adds the
end of the comment. So here's the beginning of
the comment. And here's the end. And whatever
is in between these dashes is the comment.
So I'm going to put to do and link to cat photos.
So this will just remind me to do that later.
And now we can remove this h1 tag. This
was just an example. Because this app is
really this website is actually a cat photo
app. We don't need this hello world here.
But I save that, you'll see that the
Hello World is gone. And also, the comment
does not appear on the page. html five has
tags that identify different content areas.
These tags make your HTML easier to read,
and also help with search engine optimization
and accessibility. We're going to identify the
main section of this page by any main element with
a main opening tag and closing tag. So right after
the title, I'm going to put main, the code editor
automatically puts the closing tag, I'm going to
do Ctrl x or Command X to cut it. So I'm gonna
cut this closing tag and paste it right here.
And this is a good time to talk about nesting.
HTML elements are often nested within other
HTML elements. So on this page, we have this
body element right here, this is the opening
tag and ending tag. And inside the body element
is all this stuff right here, which is nested,
and the body element is actually nested within the
HTML element. And we have this main element inside
nested within the main element is this comment in
this paragraph tag, what I'm going to do is select
everything within the main element. And I'm going
to hit the Tab key that's going to indent all
of the everything within the main element.
indentation spacing, and new lines do not impact
how a browser renders a page. But it can make HTML
easier to read. And the general best practice is
to indent all nested elements. So you can see this
is indented. And then this is indented. And this
is indented. So every sect, anything that's nested
is indented within the elements that is nested
in. And you can see when I select this, you can
see these little dots, those are spaces. So though
I just click the tab button to indent this, and it
just added two spaces before each line. So you
could also just use the spacebar to indent those,
this page is going to have a few different
sections. So we'll indicate the first section
by adding an h3 element with the text cat
photos above the comment. So I'm going to put
h3 here, photos. And if I refresh, you'll see
that we have this is the H two heading and this
is the h3 heading, it's just a little smaller. Now
we're going to make this look a little cooler by
adding an image. So right after this paragraph,
I'm going to put an image tag. Now an image tag
and image element does not have a closing tag,
it only has an opening tag, it just has one tag.
Most elements have an opening and closing tag.
But there are some elements that only have a
single tag, they don't have a closing tag. But
we are going to have to do something to specify
what the image is that's going to display.
And that's where HTML attributes come in.
html attributes are special words used inside the
opening tag of an element to control the elements
behavior. So let me show you how to do that
in an image element. So in this image element,
I'm going to put a space, I'm putting the
space before the closing bracket. And I'm
gonna put SRC stands for source, the source of
the image will be equals. And then I'm going
to put a website here. So it's gonna be HTTPS,
colon slash slash, FCC that I am slash FCC, re.
Relaxing cat. Now this is the URL of an
image that already exists on the internet.
So if I save this and I refresh the page,
we see this cute relaxing cat right here.
So it's displaying this image and the source
of the image is this URL, it's getting the
image from that URL. So this is the attribute
and attributes are always paired with values.
There's always in the value here is this the
value is always going to be in quotation marks.
attributes are selected from a predefined set of
possible attributes depending on the element. So
SRC is specific to an image element and a few
other elements. And depending on the element,
there'll be a different list of attributes
that can go along with it. But the values are
more variable, they're going to be in quotation
marks. And they could be lots of different things
depending on what applies to the attribute. And
we're going to add another attribute right now. So
after this attribute and value, I'm going
to put a space and then this is going to be
an alt attribute. So the value of this alt
is just going is going to be a cute orange
cat lying on its back. So an alt attribute is
basically a way to describe the picture with
text. The text inside an alt attribute is used
for screen readers to improve accessibility.
And it's displayed if the image fails to load.
So you should always use an alt attribute with
every image. Now we'll add an anchor element that
will link to another website, an anchor element,
or the A element can is used to create a link that
you click on to go to a different page or website.
So let me show you how to do that. It's just
a four anchor. And then we have the opening
and closing tags. But we're going to specify
what the website that we're linking to is.
So to specify that we're going to use an attribute
called href. equals and then here's where we're
going to put the website we're linking to.
For this example, I'm just going to put cat
photos, calm, cat photos, calm. And then inside.
So we have this opening tag and this closing tag.
And whatever is in between the opening and
closing tag of an anchor element is what
the text is of the link. So I'm going to put cat
photos. So if I save this and I refresh over here,
we can see cat photos. And I realize I forgot
to put the HTTPS, colon slash slash. So we need
that this part for the links. And now if I save
this refresh here, that click on and cat photos,
this is not a real website. It's just an example
website for this. So it just says it cannot be
reached. But that's how you create a link. Next
thing is I'm going to actually put this link
into this paragraph, see how we have the word cat
photos here, I want the link to be right there.
So I'm going to cut this out Ctrl or Command x.
And now I'm going to select this text cat photos,
delete that Ctrl V to paste in the link, I save
that and then refresh, we can now see that the
link is right in that sentence. It's right in that
paragraph. Now you saw when I clicked on this,
it just opens right in the same tab. But what
if I want to open up into a new tab? Well,
we need another attribute. So right in this anchor
tag, I'm going to write after the href attribute,
I'm gonna put a space and then add another
attribute, it's going to be the target attribute,
target equals underscore blank. Now, if I refresh
this, I click here, it opens up a new tab,
the website still doesn't exist, though. Since
this isn't a real website, we're not actually
even going to use it here. I'm going to erase this
URL here, and just put a hash sign or pound or a
number sign here. This will keep the text as a
link, but it will no longer link to anything.
It's just a placeholder. It's also often used when
changing the behavior of a link using JavaScript.
So if I just refresh here, I click here,
it still opens in a new tab, but it just
loads the same website in that new tab. And we can
turn this image into a link, I just have to put
an anchor tag here, there's opening anchor
tag, I'm going to copy the closing tag,
I'm going to cut it and put it at the end. And now
I'm going to put h ref. And I'm just going to put
in a placeholder link in here. So if I refresh
here, if I move my mouse over the cat photo,
you can see it turns into a pointer because
it's a link. Now, if I click here, you can see
nothing really happens because it's just the
placeholder and it's not opening into a new,
it's not opening into a new tab. So
it just basically refreshes the page,
or really does nothing when I click there. It's
finally time for a new section of the page. So
before the closing of this main element, I'm going
to add another heading and H three. And this is
going to say cat lists. And now we're going to
learn how to create lists in HTML. The first list
is going to be things cats love. So let me
add a new paragraph. This is things cats love.
And then after this, I'm going to add an
unordered list ul, this ul element is an
unordered list. And you can see I put the
opening and closing tags on different lines.
Because in between, we're going to put three list
items. The first thing cats love are is catnip.
And then another list item is laser pointers.
And the final list item is lasagna. And
now I'm going to add after this list,
well, before I add this next thing, let's
check what it looks like in the browser.
So here is the unordered list, we see these bullet
points and we see the three items. After this, I'm
going to add an image of one of the things on the
list. So put the image tag, and then I'll put that
SRC the source of this image, instead of linking
to a URL like the other image on the page,
we're going to link to a file right on my
computer, I'm just going to put was on dot jpg.
And then for the alt tag, is
going to be who is on Yeah.
Now before I refresh my page, I want to show you
something. So in the same folder on my computer
with my HTML file, I also have this lasagna dot
jpg. So as long as you have an image in the same
folder as your HTML file, you can just link to
it by putting the file name right in here. And
then when we upload our files to our web server
to host our website elsewhere, there's also going
to be folders there. And we just have to make
sure that images are in the right folder here.
So if I refresh my page, we should see a picture
of lasagna, one of the things that cats love,
in the description of this video, I have a link,
so you can download the picture yourself to put
it into your website. Now we're ready for another
list. And this time, it's going to be things cats
hate. So this time, instead of using an unordered
list, I'm going to put in an ordered list o l,
and they're going to be three list
items. The first item is flea treatment.
Second list item is thunder. And the third
list item is other cats. Oops, oh I other cats.
Let's see what that looks like. So you can
see the ordered list is numbered, we have 123
here of the things that cats hate, I'm going to
add another image right below this. So image SRC
in this image is called cats that jpg. All cats.
And just like before I have the link to this image
in the description in this image is already in the
same folder as my HTML file. So if I refresh here,
we see three cute cats, which are things that cats
hate. Well, at least according to this website,
on the internet. And as you know, you
can believe most things on the internet.
But cats don't just kind of hate these
things. They really hate these things.
So around the word hate, I'm going to surround it
in a strong element. So I'll put strong and this
closing tag, I'm going to cut this closing tag
and put it at the end of the word hate. So now,
if I refresh this, you can see that this is bold
here. And we're going to do something similar
for things cats love. I'm going to surround
this in an E m tag to emphasize the word love,
which is also the same as italicize. So if I save
this and refresh, we can see things get love. And
we have italicized here. Now we're going to add
another common thing on website, which is a form.
So we're going to add a form element with an
opening with an opening and closing form tag.
So right after this image, I'm going to put form
and then I'll put those on different lines there
will indicate where to submit the form data by
adding an action attribute on the form element.
So it's gonna look like this. action equals
slash submit cat photo Just like that. So now
when you submit this form, we still have to
add the submit button. But once we do when
you click the submit button, it will submit
all the data to that URL. Now, we're not going
to actually create that part of this website.
This is just a basic HTML Crash Course. So we are
not going to do anything to handle this form data,
I'm just going to show you how to create the
form. And you'll have to look for another
tutorial to learn how to create the website that
handles that form submission. But the first thing
in this form is going to be a text input element.
So right here, I'm going to put an input element,
and I'm going to add a type. And the type is going
to be text, this is going to make a text box. So
if I save this and refresh over here, we can
see at the very end, this text box, which I can
put all these any, any text in this text box down
here, input elements do not need closing tags,
we're going to add placeholder text to this input.
So this is going to be another attribute place.
place holder equals cat photo URL. So placeholder
tags, you're just about to see what that is. But
it's this light gray text that appears in
the in this input box until you start typing.
As soon as you start typing, it goes away.
So that can indicate what's supposed to go
into the input box. Under this input element,
I'll add a submit button. So this is going to be
a button element. And it's going to have a type
of Submit. And this is this is going to have a
closing tag opening and closing tag. And whatever
text you put in between the opening and closing
tag of a button is going to appear on the
button. In this case, we'll have it say Submit.
So if I save that, and then I refresh, we can
see that there's a submit button right here.
Now if I click the submit button, remember, we
haven't implemented what happens after you click
the submit button at that URL. But that's how
you would submit the data. Clicking the button
will send the data from the form to the URL
we specified in this action attribute up here.
Let's make it so it's required to put it in
the URL before we can click the submit button.
That's pretty simple. Just in this input to
make that input required. I'm going to put an
attribute required. Most attributes have values.
But in this case, this does not have a value,
it's just the attribute use that to put the
word require doesn't have to equal anything.
And now if I try to click the submit button, it
says please fill out this field. You can use radio
buttons for questions where you want the user to
only give you one answer out of multiple options.
Here's how you put a radio button, we're going
to put two radio buttons for an indoor or outdoor
cat. So right before this text box, I'm going to
put an input element. And that type this time is
going to be radio. And then I'm just going to put
indoor. And then I'll put another one input type
equals radio. And this is going to
be out door. I save this and refresh.
You can now see indoor and outdoor. Right now, if
you click on it, they both stay clicked. So we're
going to eventually make it so when you click on
one it unclicks the others you can only have one
clicked at a time. We also want to make it so when
you click on the text, it will make the button
clicked. To make the text also click the button
we're going to nest everything within a label
element. So I'm going to put a label and then
this closing tag, I'm going to cut that and put
it at the end here. And you can see it does. Go
to the next line. And then I'll put a label here.
And then I'll cut this label and then put
it here and I'm going to save and refresh.
And now if I click the text outdoor, the
radio button clicks click the text indoor
the indoor button clicks. All related radio
buttons should have the same name attribute
to create a radio button group. By creating a
radio group selecting any single radio button
will automatically the Select To the
other buttons within the same group,
ensuring only one answer is provided by the user.
So I'm going to add the attribute indoor outdoor
to each radio button. So here it goes
right here, I'm going to put name, indoor,
outdoor. And since I'm adding the same one to
every radio button, I'm just going to copy this.
And I'm going to paste it.
Now if I refresh, we have indoor. So when I click
one, the other one D selects. Next up, I'm going
to add an ID attribute to these buttons. an ID
attribute is used to identify specific elements
in other sections of HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
So I'm going to add an ID attribute set to equal
indoor on the first real input element. And Id
attributes have to equal outdoor on the secondary
input element. So I'm going to put the ideas I'm
going to put as the first attribute ID equals
indoor. And then ID equals outdoor. Now one
thing about these attributes is that the order
doesn't matter. So you can see on this
input element, there's three attributes,
there's the ID, the type and the name, the order
doesn't matter. I could have put name, type ID,
or type ID name, the order doesn't matter. So
it's as long as you have a space in between
each element, or each attribute, it's going to all
all work, it's considered best practice to set a
four attribute on the label element with a value
that matches the value of the ID element of the
input element. This allows assisting technologies
to create a linked relationship between the label
and the child input element. So let me show
you how you would do that. It's very simple.
So for this label, I'm going to put four and
that's going to be set to the same thing as ID,
which is indoor. So now we know that this label
is for this input, because it has the same
the for indoor, oh, but I door indoor. And
we'll do the same thing right down here,
for out door, and racist extra space. So
yeah, now we know this labels for this input,
I'm going to actually zoom out a little bit on
the code. So you can see more of what's going
on. It doesn't it doesn't go to the next line as
much doesn't wrap to the next line quite as much.
Now, none of this stuff, we did actually
change what the web page looks like. But we
are just about to change something, you can see
everything's on the same line, indoor outdoor,
and this text, this text box are all on the same
line. This is because line breaks in HTML have no
impact on how a browser renders the page. To
add a line break, we're going to use the br
tag for break. So after this first indoor one I'm
going to put BR and I'm just going to copy this.
And I'm going to put a br tag after each
of these input elements. And if I save that
refresh, now you can see we've indoor line
break, outdoor line break, and then the text box.
And then there's another line break and then the
submit button forms commonly used checkboxes for
questions that may have more than one answer.
The code for a checkbox is very similar to that
of a radio button. So let me show you how to add a
checkbox, we're going to add a check box to check
if a cat is loving or not the personality
of the chat the personality of the cat.
So here, I'm going to put a label just like
the radio buttons, and it's going to be for
loving. Then I'm going to put the input element
and input elements going to have an ID
of loving. It's going to have a type of
check box, Matt add some more quotation marks
here. And is going to have a name of personality.
And then I'm just going to have to put the word
loving that's the word that's going to appear.
And you know, let's just make this
consist we'll have this have a capital I
capital O. Okay, let me refresh.
And so we've been indoor, outdoor,
and we can check loving, we can check it
off and on. Let's add a line break here.
And then I'm going to add two more checkboxes,
I'm just going to copy this checkbox.
And then put two more in here. Now I'm going to
add some line breaks in the HTML, which will not
appear on the website. This is just to make
it easier to see the difference. So we have
the radio buttons, and we have the three
checkboxes. But we're going to put some
more personality traits. So this one is
going to be lazy, some cats are lazy.
And the next one is going to be energetic, and
energetic. Now let's save this and refresh. So
now we can see the radio buttons, we have these
checkboxes where you can check any number of
things. And we have this text box
where you can type in stuff here.
To set a checkbox or radio buttons to be
checked by default, just add the word checked
to the inside of the input element. Let me show
you. So we have this input element right here,
I'm just going to add the word checked.
This is an attribute with no value.
So we have checked there, and then
I'm going to add checked here.
I can spell it. There we go, refresh. And now
the indoor is automatically checked and loving
is automatically checked. We're getting close to
being done with this page. And I'm finally going
to tell you about one of the most commonly used
HTML elements of all, which is the div element,
also known as a division element. It's a
general purpose container for other elements.
One of the reasons it's used so much is because
div elements are often used to target with CSS.
So you may want to style a whole section
of your web page in one particular way. And
you can wrap that all within a div element. And
then you can use CSS to style that div element.
So we're going to put our lists in a div element.
So I'm going to put an opening div tag here.
And then we have the closing div tag, I'm just
going to cut this, I will actually zoom in on
the code just a little bit more. And at the end
of things, cats hate the end of this other list,
I'm going to put the closing div element.
Now I'm going to indent everything in here.
So you can see it's nested within the div.
So now we can see that inside this div,
we have the things cats love, and that things
cats hate. So the way that you would often style
something like this with CSS is to add a class
attribute. So I'm going to put class equals lists.
Class attributes are very commonly used in
HTML, specifically to style with CSS. So you
can actually target all elements with the class
of lists to make them have all the same style.
So maybe you went everything with the class of
list like this to have a blue background. Or maybe
you want to border around everything. Or maybe you
want all the text to be a different color, or the
text size we different. And you can in the CSS,
you can actually target anything with the clip
anything inside a div with class lists can have
a certain style. Now, we're not going to go too
far into that, because again, this course is just
about HTML, you'll just have to look at an S CSS
course to learn more about that. So now we're
going to add a footer to the web page. So we have
the main section, we hit the closing main tag,
I'm going to add a footer element. Now, the stuff
inside a footer element is not going to look any
different on your page. This is mainly for screen
readers and SEO purposes. So so the different
sections of your web page can be identified.
And inside this footer, we're going to put a
paragraph tag, it's going to say no copyright
free code camp.org. So if I save this
and refresh, we can see no copyright
free code camp.org and we can make this
into a real link by putting a href equals
http colon HBS colon slash slash, Free Code,
camp that org and then I have to put this closing
in element, the closing tag after the Free Code
camp.org text here. So they save that and refresh.
Now we see this is now a link to Free Code Camp
that org. And one other thing I want to show you
is that we could style a lot of times the text
and a footer is smaller. Now we could style that
with CSS, or we can just put a small tag around
everything. So when we put the closing small tag
at the end here, and save that, if I refresh,
you can see now this text is a little smaller.
Now let's go all the way back up to the top of our
HTML page. And we'll look at this HTML element,
you'll notice that everything is inside the HTML
element. And inside this, we are going to specify
the language of the website, we want to specify
that this isn't in English. So up at Lang
equals e en for English. And I told you earlier
that before the body section of a website,
you'll often have a head section of
a website. And so let's add that now.
Got the head section, the head section is where
it where metadata elements go sub sub that's not
going to actually show up in the content of your
website. Things such as link meta title style.
So let me give you an example. One of One very
common one is title. So I can create a title
for this website, I'm going to put cat photo
app. I'm going to save this and see how here it
says index that HTML if I refresh, now it says cat
photo app sitting that right from the title here.
Another thing that's common to use in the
head, or to put in the head of a website
is links to the external CSS file that's going
to be used to style the page and the external
JavaScript file that's going to be used to add
functionality to your page. And actually, that's
it. This is a complete HTML page that we have
created. So the next step is to update this to
our web hosting provider. So we can actually get
this website on the internet. so other people can
go to a URL to access this website with hosting,
or you can deploy websites directly. If you
haven't learned tools like Git and Linux yet, this
approach can save you a lot of time and stress,
start off by going to a hosting or.com. And
you can click Start now or just scroll down.
And I would recommend if you're just starting
out, just go with the cheapest option the single
shared hosting. And we'll just select that. And
then you just go through this checkout process,
choosing the options you want, you'll probably
I would recommend the 12 month option. And then
you just put in your payment information. I'm
not going to show you the full account creation
process. But after you get your account created,
you'll get logged in, it's possible during the
account creation process, you will have chosen
a domain name. If you haven't, there could be a
button on this screen to create a domain name.
So if I scroll down, I can see at the very
bottom amazing cat photos.com, the domain name I
got for our awesome website that we just created.
So to upload the photos to the website, we'll
have to go to hosting I'm going to go to this
menu up here and click hosting. Now amazing cat
photos calm I'm going to manage the hosting.
Okay now we just have to scroll down to
this file section and I go to File Manager.
So now I'm going to make sure to go into
the public HTML directory and there may
be something in this folder if there is just
delete it so you have nothing in the folder.
And now I'm just going to add my files I can
either drag them in from a folder on my computer,
or I can click Upload Files. And I was going
select the files so here are the three files
index dot HTML cat JPG and lasagna
dot JPG and open and upload.
And it's as simple as that the website should now
work you may have to wait a few hours if you just
create a your website. Sometimes it can take a few
hours from x from after you buy your website until
when you can actually go to the URL and it will go
to these files. Sometimes it can even take a day.
But once everything connects and everything
works, then if you make any changes it will
happen instantly. Just the first time when
you get set up it could take a little while.
So let's try going to the website. So I'll
go to WWW dot amazing cat photos calm. If
you try and it doesn't work you may have to
hit you may have to add the www That at the
beginning of the URL so www dot amazing cat
photos calm and this is the website we created
awesome hosting are made that super easy.
Okay you know the basics of HTML. The
next step is to start learning CSS and
JavaScript. Well thanks for watching.